trabajan esas tareas a contrarreloj
porque como bien decías que eran menos
de 15 horas de oxígeno dentro de ese
sumergible y el tiempo apremia ha habido
momentos de Esperanza cuando se han
escuchado esos cuando se han captado
esos sonidos del océano ayer Los captó
un avión canadiense sonidos unos
pequeños golpes con intervalos de 30
minutos que se repetían y hoy se han
vuelto a captar otra vez aunque desde la
guardia costera de momento dicen que no
saben Cuál es el origen de esos ruidos
de esos pequeños golpes es algo que está
investigando ahora mismo la Marina de
Estados Unidos pero sí que ha servido
para acotar la zona de actuación donde
se está buscando a esos cinco
tripulantes que hasta ahora era
tremendamente inmensa Así que se está
permitiendo Buscar solamente en esa zona
de donde proceden esos sonidos esos
ruidos y mientras tanto pues no se
pierde la esperanza y ahora han dicho
desde la guardia costera que en misiones
así la esperanza no se pierde nunca y
por eso no deja de llegar ayuda nacional
se ha incorporado también el ejército
estadounidense y canadiense y ayuda
también internacional
Amén hablemos de las cuestiones de
seguridad del sumergible desaparecido
que señalan las últimas actualizaciones
al respecto
si desde la propia página web de la
empresa propietaria de este sumergible
ya reconocen que el artefacto submarino
no está homologado dicen que no está
homologado porque es tan moderno que
digamos no encajaría en el marco legal
de la industria naval Esto es algo que
aparece en el documento que firman los
pasajeros una vez van a subir a este
sumergible llamado titán un documento en
el que también se dice que este se trata
de un artefacto experimental y que puede
causar y que puede haber daños puede
haber emergencias y que se puede llegar
incluso a la muerte Este es el documento
que firman los pasajeros son conocedores
de todo ello lo que no se sabe si
también eran conocedores es que en el
2018 una treintena de expertos en
vehículos sumergibles advirtió a la
empresa de que esta este enfoque
experimental que estaba llevando a cabo
no era seguro y podía acabar en daños
que iban desde daños pequeños a daños
catastróficos